one of the things that donald trump and
others have pretended to care about is
that wind turbines for generating wind
power
sometimes kill birds you want to see a
burv graveyard you just go take a look a
bird graveyard
go under a windmill someday now it is
true that wind turbines sometimes lead
to the death of birds but what's really
important to understand is that energy
derived from fossil fuel kills way more
animals when you consider destruction of
habitats
the effect on the climate of the planet
oil spills when you add that all up the
number of animals being killed by fossil
fuels is way more than the number of
birds being killed by wind turbines but
need be that as it may it'd be great to
reduce the number of birds killed by
wind turbines and scientists have found
that if you paint one of the blades of
the wind turbine you dramatically reduce
the number of birds that are killed
we're going to continue improving this
is just the beginning you know i know
windmills very much i've studied it
better than anyone